hace varios años cuando tomé la decisión
de avanzar en mi carrera como gerente
general una persona me pregunta
realmente está segura de que eso es lo
que quieres hacer ha analizado bien ese
siguiente paso que como gerente general
quieres dar en tu carrera
me decía el sector de las bebidas
alcohólicas no está hecho para mujeres
quiero avanzar compartiendo lees un
texto publicado por la academia
estudios y de filosofía de la
universidad de navarra
se refiere al coraje coraje es la
capacidad de sobreponerse a dificultades
que pueden presentarse cuando se
persigue una meta
se comporta con coraje quien se conoce y
se acepta como es tanto sus fortalezas
como sus oportunidades sabe cuál es su
objetivo y por qué lucha distingue lo
que vale la pena aunque suponga
enfrentarse a peligros y dificultades
elige lo mejor a pesar del riesgo o la
dificultad
no se deja llevar por lo fácil ni por lo
que da más dinero o prestigio se
enfrenta a los obstáculos que surgen
mientras camina a su meta
no se refugia en el pasado acepta las
cosas nuevas que están por venir no se
deja intimidar y atrapar por el dolor
aceptando el sufrimiento con libertad
el coraje se adquiere afrontando nuevos
retos con ilusión se trata de buscar
soluciones y ser creativos frente a los
obstáculos ante las dificultades que
surgen hay que confiar en que siempre se
puede salir adelante tener las
capacidades para afrontar el mundo real
como es
no como quisiéramos que fuera y es así
como quisiera compartirles que soy
nacida en venezuela soy nacida en esta
tierra soy hija de padres inmigrantes
cubanos trabajadores de clase media que
nos criaron con grandes valores
familiares con grandes principios
morales y de y de ética y al tiempo que
con grandes sacrificios pues también nos
proporcionaron afortunadamente la
posibilidad de tener estudios académicos
y ese es uno de los grandes
digamos regalos que la vida nos dio dos
de nuestros padres al podernos
proporcionar educación hace muchos años
cuando inicié quizás algunos de ustedes
no bien me ha sido todavía cuando eso en
mi carrera profesional ya hace más de 26
años en mis primeros roles y quisiera
conectar con lo que les acabo
es ese momento del profesional que se
siente lleno de energía y que cada reto
que cada paso que cada diría oportunidad
que se abre en el camino pues lo
aceptaba con muchísima ilusión y eso no
ha cambiado aún en día es por eso que
entre otros elementos que quiero contar
de lo que es mi experiencia profesional
en estos primeros años de carrera que yo
había marcado mucho mi
digamos en el área en la que me
desarrolle y en lo que he llegado a
hacer hoy en día entre otros elementos
quisiera regalarles por favor actúen con
determinación sigan adelante en todas
las metas que se proponen seguir mi
camino como profesional en esa gran
compañía a la fecha por cierto cuatro
grandes compañías multinacionales en el
país en la cual me he sentido muy
orgullosa a lo largo de todos estos años
he visto lo bueno y lo no tan bueno de
lo que ha sido la prosperidad o no pues
de las organizaciones en venezuela a lo
largo de todos estos años y bueno un
poco a poco en esta en este devenir de
la carrera de lo que iba avanzando tuve
la oportunidad bueno pues de tomar
proyectos de cambiar de ciudad
yo soy estudié en la universidad carmen
escuela ubicada en valencia luego tuve
unos proyectos unas asignaciones
especiales en los proyectos en la ciudad
para acá y esos pequeños cambios pues
fueron construyendo desde mi espacio
obviamente un crecimiento en una joven
después
un poco más adelante me vine a vivir a
caracas y ya desde el año 97 vivo acá y
se reina acá y se familia acá y también
pues pasé por algunas situaciones
difíciles que ya les voy a comentar
porque muchas veces pensamos que cuando
vemos a una persona en un rol quizás
ningún ejecutivo del mundo corporativo
pensamos que su vida es perfecta y la
realidad que no lo es así o sea eso es
una situación que la vida no es una
línea recta no es una línea recta
horizontal no es una línea ascendente o
descendente simplemente la vida sube y
baja sube y baja y todos tenemos que
tener ese espacio de valentía de
determinación pues para salir adelante y
garantizar que nuestros sueños se hagan
realidad llegue a caracas y en el
espacio decidí creciendo algo adicional
que quisiera pues compartirle tiene que
ver con tener humildad para aprender
hambre y ganas de aprender de tus
compañeros de diferentes organizaciones
y en aquel momento se estaba cualquier
reto cualquier función cualquier
aprendizaje tuve la oportunidad
en ese momento formarme en una
organización que recordaran quizás en el
momento era la venezuela próspera muy
boyante donde inclusive en los negocios
de venezuela eran tan lo cual importante
comparar latinoamérica para las regiones
de latinoamérica tales como méxico o
brasil
entonces eran organizaciones muy grandes
muy exigentes y obviamente la
preferencia por el mercado venezolano
por los cubre el nivel de consumo que en
esos momentos estaba presente sigo
avanzando un cambio de organización en
ese momento esa corporación pues tenía
varias compañías igual en el mundo
corporativo y finalmente llegó al área
de finanzas un área que que realmente me
ha formado de manera importante de
manera yo diría general y holística y
que me ha permitido pues también
complementar el resto de los roles que
hoy también como gerente general tengo
sobre mi responsabilidad
en el área de finanzas pues la verdad es
que llegó allí un poco por ese espacio
de curiosidad y ganas por aprender por
tener sentido de dueño de negocio y por
querer que cada día las cosas siguiesen
adelantes fundamentalmente en el área de
análisis tuve la oportunidad pues
también de poder trabajar siempre de la
primera mano con directores de primera
línea con gerentes generales de primera
línea a quienes de verdad tengo que
agradecer porque mucho del espacio que
de pronto pensamos es bueno porque es
mujer o porque es hombre y yo la verdad
que solamente tengo que agradecer a
todas las personas que han estado lo
largo de mi carrera quienes me han
guiado quienes me han dado feedback
quienes han sido mis mentores y quienes
me han orientado inclusive hemos tenido
discusiones de negocio interesante
porque gracias a esa
discusiones gracias a esas interacciones
obviamente ha complementado mi formación
profesional seguí avanzando y llegó un
momento en mi vida que me
balance de trabajo de pronto no era el
que yo esperaba ya me había casado tenía
hijo y tomé la decisión de hacer un
cambio radical en mi vida en ese momento
con mucho coraje y determinación decidí
cambiar mi vida y decidí pasar a una
organización otra multinacional del
sector de la industria farmacéutica que
me iba a proporcionar tener calidad de
trabajo seguir desarrollándome
profesionalmente pero al mismo tiempo
poder tener calidad de vida en esta
organización también crecí fue a lo
largo de varios años pude tener mi
primer rol de dirección salí del área de
finanzas me fue a la dirección de
desarrollo de negocios luego olvida
finanzas como directora de finanzas en
un negocio grandísimo grandísimo
grandísimo nunca me imaginé pues que
este nivel de exigencias iba a ser de
tal manera y con mucha determinación
sentía que como directora de finanzas
necesitaba lograr algunas otras
experiencias y competencias siendo
desarrollando media ese rol y es por eso
que tomó la decisión de irme a otra
organización en venezuela esta vez
en el área de alimentos donde quería
complementar mi carrera de finanzas
pudiendo tener planta es decir
producción local y algunos otros
elementos que también me complementarían
en mi carrera avance durante tres años
fui directora de finanzas de esta
organización y el tercer año ocupe el
rol del gerente general con muchísimos
retos en una organización de consumo
masivo yo tengo que realmente agradecer
a todas las personas que me acompañaron
pues en ese desarrollo tres grandes años
en mi primera experiencia como gerente
general difícil pero realmente yo le
llamaría y ahora
sabes que finalmente al día estás
poniendo el producto en el anaquel qué
orgullo y que estás
en ese momento teníamos un propósito de
nutrir a las familias para que puedan
crecer y prosperar
como la siguiente decisión que es como
inició esta pequeña conversación del día
de hoy buscando crecer como gerente
general en unos espacios de experiencia
que me permitiera capitalizar y adquirir
y contribuir con base a los aportes en
áreas de exportación también en áreas de
producción en un sector de bebidas
alcohólicas que era distinto a todo el
barrio al profesional pues que yo tenía
y yo estaba determinada que yo en el rol
de gerente general yo quería crecer
igual que si fue salir de mi zona de
confort entonces todo esto ha llevado a
concluir este espacio esta conversación
muy breve de más de 26 años de
experiencias profesional a conjugar
también un espacio familiar durante esos
años
en momentos muy difíciles estuve en
proceso de divorcio me divorcié
y me tuve que mudar de residencia que
son situaciones de vida que realmente
complementan o influyen o impactan en el
desempeño de un profesional pero con eso
les quiero decir que la vida de nadie es
perfecta que no necesariamente el pasto
verde es el vecino a veces el pasto
verdes del propio y que solamente con
determinación con confianza les invito
por favor la vida es una haga su sueño
en realidad muchas gracias